this is Startalk I'm your host Neil
deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist and I'm also director of
New York City's Hayden Planetarium at
the American Museum of Natural History
and I got with me my coach Chuck nice
Chuck a baby how are you tweeting a
chuck nice comment thank you sir yes I
follow you by the way I follow you too I
might follow you in a list I have a lot
of lists that I fall because I follow
comedians and science entities which
includes like the Pentagon and you know
the Navy and DARPA all right and Chuck
somebody will find your Twitter profile
and be like how did Chuck hack his
Twitter profile well today we're
exploring the science of the singing
voice through my interview with
singer-songwriter Kelly Clarkson in fact
the full interview because for this week
cut and paste for this the full
interview is available on this Startalk
youtube channel very nice right and her
newest album which is how she landed in
our universe is called the meaning of
life that's how that's how this happened
let me tell you if right clarkson is
telling me the meaning of life we have
in studio expert guest because I am no
VOC vocalist or vocal I sing really good
in the shower well you know your
speaking voice would betray the fact
that you might be able to sing well in
the shower that's it okay the acoustics
in the shower make or a by sound good a
guest today is Professor and performer
Brian Gill welcome to the show Brian hey
thank you very much so you are I got
here you are associate professor a voice
yes that's a thing yes and voice
pedagogy and voice data coaches yes
Indiana University yes this is in
Bloomington Indiana Indiana yes lovely
little college town the Jacobs School of
Music yes that's a beautiful thing yeah
and it says here you're a vole colleges
yes yes that's that's just wrong that
shouldn't be a work they made I'm sorry
I won't be in this Friday I have an
appointment with my book ecology just
could you good at the thing doesn't mean
you put all of this on it that's another
thing I'm a funny ologist
right complete balance so you're a tenor
yes and you perform your performer as a
tenor an opera a musical theater love
musical theater and concert recitals in
the US and in Europe I feel privileged
that you're you're in town privileged to
be here as we snatched you out of you
are gonna head back to Indiana yesterday
yes yes and going back tonight and and
we delayed your plane trouble on the
tarmac I got a no I got people I got I
know the guy checks the engines right
you see that dude out there with the two
light cones that lit up Coney dragged me
off I have to ask what specifically is
vole ecology it's the it's the quick
definition science and practice of voice
habilitation and if necessary
rehabilitation
oh now I know what an habilitation yeah
I never knew we all know what
rehabilitation is but nobody ever
habilitated le really private yeah I do
have bill it takes it yes it later wait
till it's broken
wait so habilitated the what would that
be then this is the sustenance and care
and feeding of your you teach you teach
a person so you really high-level
functions so you do not injure your so
you don't answer yes then you don't have
to read it that's right because it's
more difficult to rehabilitate than
hability that once the system's broken
to get the pieces back together
including the mind and how the person
reacted to the injury or the breakdown
of the system is very difficult Wow no
you're a little singer when you have a
singing injury
my rotator cuff and a part of common
unfortunately due to injury for the
season yes what happens but and it
covers it covers any professional voice
user which would also be someone like
you all that use your voice in this
medium great so we do so if something
happens with a politician or our teacher
at school or something because they have
a heavy voice load then of ecologist is
uniquely trained to help them I remember
Bill Bill Clinton yes I remember he
needed yeah and he ran into he already
sounded like this to begin with yeah I
just want to let you know that I talk
like this because I'm not habilitative
and I remember he was either campaigning
for himself for Hillary or Barack Obama
I'm not sure anyway he had to come off
the campaign trail because he lost he
had injured his voice and they call it
an injury yeah a really common thing
unfortunately okay militated interesting
thanks nice we'll be drawing on your
expertise heavily for this conversation
that I've had with Kelly Clarkson she's
been judge is one of the best vocalists
in the industry she's a powerhouse voice
from the versatile mm-hmm so 25 million
albums 36 million singles worldwide and
she was the first artist in history I
got I got crack team of researchers here
to top each a Billboard's pop adult
contemporary country and dance charts
Wow and only two of those actually count
country country tried to ask her about
her newest album the meaning of life
nice yes so let's just just straight up
let's figure out where that came from
check now so the meaning of life is
you're a
album yes and now forgive me I haven't
heard all your albums yes but I heard
this I'm so offended but this one I've
heard you're the stuff that is charted
awful Khan's albums of course I've heard
those in this album it is it's there's a
soulfulness to it yes that but it has
sort of pop roots bringing soul into it
and I'm when I'm old enough that I'm
trying to do they have put this album in
the stove-piped
categories in a record shop yeah and I
don't think there's a spot no I mean
it's I guess a pop pop just because no
no you know there's too much soul excuse
me because you sing and I just have to
stop what I'm doing and just do it
where's a pop song you can keep cooking
you can and you shape to it but you're
not moved by it a pop song yeah that's
why it's pop because everybody likes it
yeah it's popular its popular right but
if it's if you that's another kind of oh
you made it you know it's it is soulful
pop and I it's definitely there's
definitely a difference when you listen
to this album versus the other albums I
mean one you can just I'm happy in it
and it creates a whole different that
happiness creates a whole domino effect
of different sounds and tones and and
and and even the freedom that Atlantic
has given me creates a whole different
vibe because an artist in the in their
form to where they're able to just go
okay well wait I could do whatever I
want like you know wait it's all on me
now you're accountable but luckily I
love I was telling my husband this like
even before the album dropped I was like
I've literally been waiting so long to
make this musical footprint that like
even if it didn't do as well as other
things I love I love that like I'm still
happy at the end of the day for that you
know because I've been very blessed
I've had 15 great years of success and
even if it were over me like I've had a
phenomenal career and I'm very thankful
so so Brian from a sort of VOC ologists
perspective what sets her voice apart I
love that those beautiful and now we
know that she was a miserable she's what
I'd call a thoroughbred of vocalists in
that she can do something that's a very
high demand on the voice the amount of
we call connection at the vocal fold
level and that she's all the vocal folds
are two flaps of tissue in the larynx
right here into your throat he plucked
his throat I mean a sound no I'm not
doing that to my neck I'm sorry let me
tell you something I think he's a robot
myself so hard that it hurts and I still
can't get any sound out of it yeah you
have to close the vocal folds and you'll
get it like you're lifting something you
go I'm not even attached yeah but but
she she's been able to sustain that kind
of production and really really well
over 15 I mean plus years I mean 15
years and stardom but but even longer
than that so so Brian you performed
opera mmm hard rock yes funk when I had
hair okay funk not in Indiana but jazz
even Indian classical music yes I love I
love Indian classical of these genres
not only the ones you perform there but
what Kelly Clarkson has has shined in
can you rank them based on the demands
on vocal performance mm yeah well I
think they all have different demands
especially hard rocks or the gravel
people expecting the voice and heavy
metal that kind of thing gravel me like
a Miss Johnson yeah
second noise kind of like a snarl grip
exactly yeah like you're taking a dump
and drinking jack at the same time sound
more constipated but then you get to
like for Westerners Indian classical
music involves different tonality and
that's really challenging so figuring
out how to do that luckily I was not the
lead singer I was I was the head of a
backing group behind a sorry I don't
know anything about classical music is
that the music that goes on for like a
half hour with that they can go change
yes they can go on a long time with just
a beat yeah yeah yeah okay and they kind
of so in these genres then because they
come from such different cultural places
country Indian funk pop is it technique
or do you have to actually feel it do
you need some some genetic link back
into that place to draw from in order to
perform or to excel both I think there's
a technique to it there's a way that you
use your voice that that you can
actually define in a scientific way what
the people are doing it's not it's no
longer as much of a mystery but then
there's also an exposure to a genre
that's in absolutely imperative someone
have or alpha channel truly sound like a
poser yeah you have to grow up loving it
and you might be in your under your skin
yes I have people who come to me as
opera singers and then they're like I
want to do a little bit more rock but I
was like well do you like rock not
really yeah so I asked Kelly about her
how she conveys feelings and emotions in
her singing so let's check it out that's
got me thinking I can read a poem on a
page
and it'll mean something informational e
to me perhaps but if I hear you sing it
there's a whole other conduit of
communication going on oh definitely and
are you you I you must be self aware of
that and you can go in there and you can
yeah related you how are you how do you
grok that um you know I think it's I
don't even think about I think I'm just
so I've always been touched my music
even before I knew I could sing I love
dancing I loved music I it was a safe
place for me it was like it was just a
it was a whole different kind of
learning you know just with people's
lives whether it was you know rock rap
pop like country whatever you were
listening to it's you know the music is
very good indication of the time in that
timeline that you're referring to
music if you look at it it always
follows it because we're obviously
artists are affected by our you know
nature and nurture a bit so yeah it's I
don't know what's your goal you know you
can reach people emotionally but you
also would have the capacity in a song
because a song is a story need to reach
people informational II yeah I mean
you've got your balance what's your bet
I'd like to be a you know throw a bit of
you know be a bit poetic but at the same
time keep this story simple enough to
where people aren't focused on the words
of the story it's more focused on the
feeling of the story it's more focused
on what what what that how that made me
feel and how that cuz I'm more of an
emotional person otherwise just go out
and read a damn book too many words oh
yeah and it's I don't know I've always
been the one to focus more on like I
always feel like okay I know I'm talking
about Meryl Streep a lot but my point
yet on this sure no but I'm just saying
I do but here's my point I've never said
this before but it's like I love me some
Meryl Streep oh but I feel like she's
one of those people it could be a silent
movie and she would effortlessly
flawlessly dictate by her her emotions
her eyes just her every part of her you
would know exactly what she's saying
without her saying anything through the
entire movie I think she would have been
like the most fantastic silent actress
as well
cuz she's got that art to her whole like
physical body her emotional state in her
eyes like in her mouth and her you know
all of that whether it's Miranda
Priestly or whatever character she's
playing and I'm The Devil Wears Prada so
he Shores like whatever those are she
does so much and I think that as a
singer too like that's why I try to do
like with songs I try to like you know
whatever the words are I could be not
saying words on just singing melody but
by my intensity or by the modulation of
my emotion yeah you could almost tell
the story I'm saying without even have
their being words yes so Brian is there
would you would you say there's an
evolutionary propensity to respond to a
singing voice as opposed to just a
spoken voice and and why I mean what's
if you just communicating information
I'll just utter a sentence mm-hmm but
somehow that doesn't work as well as if
I sing a sentence yes I think singing in
the and the different Tambor's that you
have and ranges that you use in singing
are more impactful with communication
you know Darwin had a thought that in
hominids like early the progenitor of
man you know that that the first
utterance were probably musical yeah and
so I mean if you think about male
species
[Laughter]
we don't have vocabulary most species
have some kind of song for for mating
and attracting people identifying you
know family and and territory and all
those things I had to ask Kelly about
the basis for the thematic basis for her
current album yeah so let's check it out
the meaning of life when you say it like
that it's far more German
that's kind of bodacious audacious yes
to be calling your how old it was bold
you can figure out the meaning of life
when you buy my album so important like
Charlie and the Chocolate Factory golden
ticket Wow okay so that means I don't
get to learn it oh no not so you get it
I'm just saying so the meaning of life
is this something you figured you've
known for a while or just came on to it
no I mean I think we're all under
construction and I think at the point of
me doing it under construction we are in
for yeah and I think that people who are
fully built no longer learning anything
well and that's first of all any person
that thinks they've got it figured out
completely is a total dork it means they
really haven't figured it out because
they haven't figured it out that they
haven't figured it out yeah what if
you're a philosopher no I do I think
that I think that meaning of life is
really just about connection and and
making sure they're positive connections
you know there's people two people yeah
well how about all the negative people
who are out there you know you just like
push them outside your bubble and you
know I do I have a tattoo for that
pastor too much people have an app for
that well cuz I really needed the daily
reminder her industry when people can be
not so lovely and so I have a tattoo and
my pastor told me this knows a kid and I
loved him he was like one of those
people that you wanted to you're like
what do you have in your life because I
want to be like you like he just had a
light about him and and I just thought
he was special and he said one time that
you know there's gonna be people in your
life and it's easy to love the lovely
people but it's not easy to love the
unlovely and and I thought that was
really poignant and I thought that you
know you have to love the people that
are unlovely even more because they
weren't loved enough so mmm missing
something in life yeah so I don't know I
think it's about just you know trying to
make this positive connections and and
and really I think it's simple I think
we complicated as humans because we try
and figure everything out and sometimes
you can't you know but you you're but
sometimes you can
your mother was a schoolteacher so who
you are making it part of your life's
mission to figure things out and at
school teacher that's what they're
trying to get their kids to figure stuff
out
yeah how much in touch you I love I mean
she always taught me to question and I
think that's the best part of whether
you're talking about faith politics life
any you know love it's always to
question it like it so I love that I
love to question whatever is happening
in the moment one to make sure it's real
and and and to just because I don't
think when you stop questioning me and
you stop asking you stop caring right I
don't know I can't say it better than
that I bet you coming up more on the
science of voice and my interview with
Kelly Clarkson
Startalk returns welcome back to you
start talk I'm with my coach Chuck nice
and our expert guest in this episode
Brian Gill professor of voice at Indiana
University have a looming yeah yeah
we're talking about this science of the
singing voice featuring my interview
with Kelly Clarkson yeah and I just had
something to follow up we talked about
your capacity to bring an emotion or an
authenticity to what it is you're saying
right and I remembered I'd like James
Taylor but not enough to buy all his
albums I waited till he had his greatest
hits and I bought the greatest hits
album yeah and on the area why were you
having trouble sleeping my sister can't
get enough of him and so goes to all his
concerts and everything and so I'm
listening to the album and and I'm a fan
of the blues right okay and in there he
has a blues song the steamroller blues
James Taylor he has a blues song and
then I said okay he's trying he's trying
yeah but you know he went to like a prep
school in Massachusetts right high
school and goes to Martha's Vineyard and
and how many blues singers ever came out
of Massachusetts yeah
so so I could woke up this morning but
the Volvo wouldn't start he does he does
drop the f-bomb though in that one he
does I think that does it just wasn't
working for me yeah he was not
convincing as a as us as it just wasn't
working yeah it wasn't working for him
either I'm letting you know well I think
the Blues is as a genre is probably the
one that you would have to feel the most
I'm thinking in order to attain or
recently the list of states the blues
singers don't tend to come from you
gotta be like from Alabama right
mississippi exactly polish chicago
louisiana right exactly you got to
there's got to be some poor black people
okay brilliant just say that is a
brilliant and the Utah Blues I'm going
right back I'm going to write that song
tonight guarantee you the Utah lose
weight let's get back to my interview
with Kelly Clarkson and see where that
takes us next check it out do you think
of your voice as an instrument that
needs cultivating and care and yes okay
yeah no I have to I mean reason why I
ask is we were in the green room before
you performed in the YouTube yes bass
and I love it they call it space yeah if
you got space in your room I'm good with
it
but before you would like just yucking
it up with everybody in the green room
and just walk out there and then out
comes this this wait is how do you wait
how well I warmed up earlier this
morning so I I oh I worked before I've
been working since this morning so I
definitely I definitely aim to warm up
everyday it's just like a speaker like a
public speaker like your your voices or
a runner your voice is a muscle you know
it's these little things that you have
to keep trained and I know some singers
don't have to I think I've heard
Jennifer in an interview Jennifer Hudson
[Applause]
well yes and she's a big vocalist and
she doesn't she said in interviews I
found it shocking she was like I don't
warm up at all it just happened so I'm
not like that I have to I have to warm
up a bit there I can do it it's just not
gonna sound as good okay not to call you
out but you are 15 years older than you
were when you been idle so it can you is
the warm-up the same oh yeah he's here
yeah I think you know it's funny I saw
Tony Bennett um no no that's fine
both names Tony and he's saying and he's
you know 80 something and I was like I
mean he killed all of us
like he he was amazing and I'm a Tony
Bennett fan but I was you know I don't
know I thought maybe the older we get
like I don't know sometimes people sound
different he sounds even better like a
fine glass of wine it's so beautiful and
I will say if you're if you're doing
things correctly and you're taking care
of yourself
and you're not ruining your cords
you know you're not reading your cords
not getting Naja you not doing things
that you're not supposed to be your
vocal cords or your musical chords you
know you hear people have enough surgery
of all that stuff if you're taking care
of yourself I think that you get better
with age your voice sounds more lived-in
and it sounds like I can go lower I can
go higher I like that phrase lived-in
yeah like a good pair of boots just to
be clear in the green room before she
went out okay I understand what she was
doing in the green dude she had friends
her husband did to her agent or book or
everybody's and she's just yucking it up
with everybody while she's eating
chicken and waffles Wow justjust
scarfing down chicken a wall so I'm
thinking that's a good warm-up is this
is C about what's about to happen after
this I'd had no idea she went out there
lip just just tore new one anyway
Oh so tell me about the anatomy of the
vocal chords so well there too and while
you add it I'd like to distinguish them
if you can from that of other primates
or anything else that would make sounds
like birds or whales yeah one of the
main things in in human beings the the
larynx which is the voice box right here
has descended and so it creates a bent
resonator that's like a space here and
then a space going this way that are
roughly about the same size before it
ended forward the other species have
relaxed its way up there and so so they
they only use it for sound and they
don't use their tongue very much for
articulation when they're making sounds
so that's unique about human beings so
so that's one of the unique features and
then you've got I mean we were with
voice you've got this power source which
is the air that comes from your lungs
you've got the tissue here the vocal
folds that vibrate that create sound and
then that sounds filtered through the
space above it so that's the basics of
the the way the instrument works
okay does that serve any purpose for us
socially or otherwise that we would be
so different yes yeah and the way we use
our voice to serves a purpose there
there was a study not too
where people could judge trustworthiness
and dominance in I think it was 500
milliseconds of listening to someone
really yeah so there was oh so so I
don't information about social
interaction is communicated just by the
tonality of your 40 milliseconds Wow so
and and so there there's certain habits
that people have that are you often
rated higher or you know like the way a
woman mount modulates the voice like
using different pitches and things like
that that's that's trustworthy person
who does that and then same thing with
Medicare valley girl that they hire and
they say now listen we have to that
that's also rated please okay so it's
not just words so for example the writer
has that challenge because if you're
just putting words on a page it's harder
to then communicate the tonality yeah
well how that's actually being expressed
so the good writers somehow get that in
that sentence right either by the pre
descriptor she responded anxiously or
she and then you put that in but you
don't need any of that if you're just
speaking it right am i gonna hear that
so you can hear okay so if you
understand the emotions like the trigger
for voice goes through the limbic system
which is part of where emotion comes
with a promise or a voice the trigger
like the the voice nerves firing trigger
or the interaction of voice with another
person it runs through the limbic system
and so emotion then can be encoded on
the voice because it's right which is
why when you were talking to someone and
you say I'm terribly sorry but I really
need you to move this along and they say
calm down and you're like it's hard to
hide it's hard I guess it's there which
was what makes a performer so unique
because they're taking they're actually
taking a signal you know what happens to
your voice if you're really upset
I mean you can't do anything so a
performers taking that signal and
they're getting just enough of the
emotional information encoding it on the
voice so that understand it yeah on
purpose in the moment but they're not
going too far so there's this whole
thing nowadays where people are trying
to push people to feel and then person
gets in there and they're like
and they can't sing right and say that's
too far so we have to figure out it's
much more complex than that you can't be
void of emotion but you also can't be
over overwhelmed by it so tell me can
you reflect on her comments about age
and what that does with your voice yeah
so first you know all the Sopranos
they're done but you know no you don't
Sopranos rare it's a rare thing
Mirella Freni those series shout out to
Marilla Franny though okay is it one of
the best in the Opera world and she's 80
something now and and still sounds
beautiful yes so what happens there's a
breakdown in the voice and one of the
things that jumped out in that clip was
I mean I believe Kelly's in her 30s yeah
so that's now that's not aging voice
that's like the prime of your life for
voice so you get in there the
musculature develops and your 30s and
into your 40s and then it starts right
around in the 50s mid 50s it starts
going downhill in that there's muscle
atrophy there's a thinning of the vocal
folds themselves and so and there's also
calcification ossification and
calcification in the vocal in Moorea
voice box yeah hurt hardening which
gives you less flexibility and so
there's a downgrading of it would make
you less versatile but it still it
wouldn't mean you still can't put some
soul definitely not elements in your
song yeah and what I think what she was
Bennett example yeah he's one of my
favorites he's one of my favorites and
actually functionally he lasted far more
than other singers of his hair if you
combine the understanding of person
gains through life that even even though
sort of lack of ability they may have or
flexibility that they may have is made
up for in their understanding of emotion
and and their more deeply grounded in
life so that shows mm-hmm interesting so
you know today I'm as I came to learn
your singing voice like most things in
society can be enhanced by technology
and I asked her ask Ellie about
auto-tune just find out how we had that
place let's check it out am I allowed to
skew in front of cameras yes you use
autotune on records yeah yeah we don't
do it live but we definitely have used
it on records are two key you cannot do
it live
yeah what you sing here comes out on the
people that do concerts that have their
own colas yeah because I know they are
in the closet auto-tune Live I don't do
that live I don't want to take away from
that emotional moment but when it's on
record I don't mind if I have I love our
performance and I'm like oh I don't I
don't know if I'm gonna nail that again
or if I even try it again and I haven't
nailed like there was just everything
was perfect but one thing I don't want
that one thing to ruin the whole whole
vibe so so I don't mind I don't mind
like using it sparingly but we
definitely don't use it a ton because
it's a major addition to the musician's
arsenal the singing Georgian and it's
there are a lot of cool things you could
do I mean I know a lot of guys in rap
use them because it sounds cool like
well that's when you we did a whole
program for Nova back when I was host of
a nova spin-off called Nova ScienceNOW
yeah I interviewed the guy who invented
auto-tune yeah and he was telling me
about what happens if you if you change
it you can manipulate it over the edge
and then it makes it funny
yeah kind of weird yeah right and which
can be cool on this we did it on
medicine on this album he made it clear
that that was not the intent the intent
is to fix your note to be the proper
note it's not to dangle off the side of
the waterfall where all these extra
weird noises come from yeah and it's
also cool like cuz how we like okay
there's a song called medicine that's
where we use it like on medicine there's
this part that goes never give me had
and they give me lit and it and I sing
it but then there's this also part they
literally took my vocal and almost like
changed it manipulated it like an octave
lower and it's like this it sounds like
a man my mom was like who's the man on
your record it was like that's my voice
they just manipulated it so there's
really cool things you can do with it I
think at the end of the day if you're
not capable of doing it live then I
don't think you should maybe that's my
personal thing but
if it's like gonna run a moment that was
really beautiful and like it you don't
want to change that moment that doesn't
bother me
yes sir Brian would you say auto-tune in
music is analogous to doping in
athletics Chuck host set a sports
spin-off of star called playing with
science and all manner of these topics
come up but I've now we have an analogue
in a whole other field you are fixing
your performance yeah well that people
will applaud rather than voice doping
yeah it's cool doping brings I mean
doping in sports brings you to the
ability to do it though life whereas
auto-tune does it all tore tune puts it
on some kind of digital format and so I
think what Kelly said is right on the
money I think if you can't do it live
what's the point because you're trying
to community can't perform any longer
and auto-tune helps you hit that no yeah
then that's to me sounds just like
doping it does just another quick one do
you think that computers will one day a
I for example will be able to not only
compose in emotional music but then
perform it in a way that we might not
even need humans because it'll know how
to maximize access to your emotional
purse strings the purse strings of
emotional strain or stress thank you I
think I'm gonna I'm gonna go on on
record saying no I don't want to he know
he don't want it by the way Brian
they'll never be able to write a funny
joke either
[Laughter]
we gotta take a quick break when
Startalk returns more of my interview
with singing sensation Kelly Clarkson
back on Startalk coach Chuck nice guest
Brian Gill yes
VOC ologist so we're featuring my
interview with singer/songwriter voice
sensation Kelly Clarkson and just before
we went to break we were talking about
whether auto-tune which put you on note
contrary to how many so many people
think of auto-tune right as doing a
funny thing Thank You Cher are you are
you and you said it was it had
meaningful analogies to doping in sports
but then during the break you mentioned
that there are actual singers who are
actually taking actual steroids yes in
support of their voice yeah
so if you for if some that are legit and
they have a big gig that they've got to
do and if you're gonna earn $50,000
you're gonna do it right and it if you
take steroids it can reduce the swelling
and enable you to get through a
performance but they're abused often so
folks behind you know they'll be
backstage and a Broadway show and
they'll be looking who has two heroes
who has steroids and looking for pills
exactly and it's usually actually
pumping iron so let's get back to my
interview with Kelly Clarkson did you
know she's also an author no I said
she's written children's books that
doesn't count let me tell you I count
there will always be children to buy
your book there's only one pool of
adults at any given time oh this is so
true and but a a brilliant marketing
scheme does not legitimacy make any how
I found out that she wrote a lullaby to
go with each one of her books so I just
have to have to get inside that and find
out what was going on school let's check
it out I also understand you got a
lullaby for each of your two books
I wrote a lullaby before the Morris
twins I love lullabies yes it was when I
was gonna write a lullaby for each one
and we might still do it but the the
Christmas one which was the second one
in the river Oh series I actually did a
full on Christmas song for because we
thought it would be cool because there's
not a lot of original Christmas songs
out there you know we always are even on
my Christmas album there's you know a
few but I love that but it's nice to do
something original every one so we did a
full on Christmas song for the second
but but there's a lullaby for the first
it's the song I came to her when she was
a baby so the series the book series
begins with what words I mean this river
rose and the magical lullabies the first
one okay river to river Rose antha River
rose in the magical alibi and then it's
River rose in the magical Christmas okay
and then we'll see more yeah there's a
whole series that I've written we'd
actually didn't plan on the Christmas
one it just came up my editor I was like
we can do that near right and he was
like aha because I really wanted it to
come out it's a fun age you know for
River Rose the real River Rose like you
know for Christmas so I thought it would
be cool she loves it so it's
kid-approved which is hard to get dampen
and it's good yeah so so I so lullabies
I think it's scientifically demonstrated
to be soothing to babies I mean we do
that empirically but yeah I think you
can study brain patterns and what parts
of it it hits and it and it calms
anxiety the speaking voice like a smooth
rather than a like your voice compared
to my speaking voice yours would be more
soothing so you can sing and I can speak
and we can let go on the road the
universe the universe so Brian is there
a definition of a lullaby uh-huh
the functional definition it's the basic
idea it's a construct of a song that's
designed to be super simple good because
with their cognitive functioning
children can't process something that's
too difficult so it has really consonant
intervals
not dissonant oh no
yep and then nursing like exactly an
additive is key right so something
that's repetitive so when it's all of
music today hey you're an idiot you're
like that's the preamble to every song
the dummies are gonna love it I tell you
my favorite lullaby oh it's feed the
bird feed the birds from Mary Poppins I
don't know it yes you do
oh my gosh and I love just the words and
she sings it to all the children to
sleep and it's a and she sings about the
bird woman at st. Paul's Cathedral
tuppence a bag tuppence tuppence
tuppence so there's a bird lady who's
homeless where you buy bags of crumbs
from her to then feed the hungry birds
on the steps of st. Paul and there's a
line which you said the Saints and
apostles look down as she sells her
wares although you can't see it you know
they're smiling each time someone shows
that he cares
oh really beautiful very beautiful it's
socially conscious and it's and these
are not infants they were there their
tweens kids or tweens and so so that's
my favorite blood you got a lullaby my
favorite lullaby sexual healing by
Marvin Gaye
Brian to sleep or get in the bed miner
my wife Kim beautiful most beautiful
soprano voice you've ever heard and she
sings to my boys every night we both do
but but she'll sing somewhere over the
rainbow to one by request she takes
request affair and then the other one
she sings the Easter Bunny has coming to
town today the Easter Bunny is coming to
town today and he just sits there seven
and nine seven and nine so you so you
married another singer yeah yeah yeah
yes because of a thing we were
performing together I heard her voice
she was rehearsing and I heard this
voice and I was like man and then later
I met her I didn't know it was her voice
and I walked up and I was like man and
then I put the two in together so
there's a mating call sound for just one
person in the world
everything else was silenced and the Sun
rose so in this last clip with Kelly I
think we bonded over the poetic beauty
of the great American total solar
eclipse of August 2017 let's check it
out
so you're from Tennessee I'm from Texas
but I've been in Tennessee for over a
decade or decade okay so you're a
resident of Tennessee what part of Texas
Fort Worth Burleson it was a bumper
sticker I remember for my wife in Texas
yeah so we have roots there all right so
Tennessee your Tennessee resident yeah
okay now I arrange to have a total solar
eclipse go completely through your state
actually Sumner County where our farm is
is exactly like one of the best places
so maybe my invitation was still in the
mail
I'll go back home and check maybe it was
there we're on our land just I would
maybe it's stolen did you have any like
Astro person on your ranch for this no
we had no scientists on the ranch you do
i I love that I appear that I have signs
he's a scientist at arm's reach well we
do have chris died on our team which
he's a genius we call him a diver on
tour but he wasn't in tennessee at the
time but yeah we we were floored though
it was one of the coolest things I've
ever been a part of followed by a moon
shadow
I was so steeped in darkness steeped in
darkness write that book right now sir
slick it seeped in darkness no I'm glad
you do you experienced it it's one of
the great spectacles of nature yes it
was it was amazing because once it
happened like literally the woods like
we have a lot of force and woods on our
land it came alive like all of a sudden
the locusts the crickets everything
everything was just like booming you
heard all that Twilight creatures yes
and everyone was so quiet because we
were you know in all of what was
happening and then all the sudden we
were like oh my gosh I mean deer like
things were just coming alive and then
it was probably very confusing then it
stopped
okay so the next time there's a total
solar eclipse over your farm you're
gonna call me up I will call you up I'm
gonna call you and you aren't gonna come
actually the next time to see it I think
is it where's the neck the next one they
said that was coming is it in 24 well
there's it eclipses every couple of
years so they're not as rare as the
press would have you believe right right
so and nowadays people with their we
have airplanes so yeah like there's one
like in South America like next year or
the year after 2019 and I think so
you're never really that far away from
the next one yeah and lately by the way
two thirds of what two-thirds of our
surfaces ocean so
they're entrepreneurial sort of ocean
people who say we'll sail our boat into
the Eclipse path and then you have an
ocean cruise the rest of the time you're
there why oh yeah
that's pretty sexy yeah totally totally
works completely nice bottle of wine
totally yes total eclipse entreated
during the Eclipse all the songs I knew
that reference the total solar eclipse
so you should look it up there's some
songs in that know you can make you can
make the Eclipse album collaborate and
you hear that Atlantic Records that's
your next you could be like the you're
the voice so you're the sexy voice in
boys to men and I'll be the singer you
do that hey baby you just come in and
you just start talking about talk
science dirty talk nerdy to me
Kelly look West look here comes the moon
shadow 1,800 miles an hour yeah there's
a cone through space of Darkness she's
every bit as fun as that conversation
sounded like it was and it sounds he
also sounded pretty authentic to me in
every way I mean I was totally like it
now made people just can be like this
you know where you kind of like you were
friends your whole life yeah yeah and
and and I used to take that personally
like wow we really bonded but I think
they're just like that right and that
anyone in a conversation with them might
feel the same way about them so so this
has that type of spirit the spirit that
that's a good word grounded
down-to-earth really Oh sounds anchored
solid person right right right right uh
I'm more of a fan after hearing your
interview with her and buy more of a fan
I mean I am now a fan I've always liked
Kelly Clarkson
so this this Eclipse song that we were
for sketching did you have a favorite
Universe song it's really not a universe
it's more of the the closest celestial
body in the solar system than it is a
universe song but fly me to the moon oh
and let me play amongst the Stars
okay so now people think of that Sauron
being about the moon but the moon is is
like the closest thing it also sings
about Jupiter and Mars that on - but let
me see what spring is like right thanks
for coming in for this you'll have to
find you again throughout please bring
me we will totally bring you back
because we get singers you know without
we could do is this singer this time you
know but if we get a VOC ologist he can
come at it from every angle you got it I
don't start using here's my car I chuck
always good having you always a place
I've been your host Neil deGrasse Tyson
your personal astrophysicist I don't
want I want to thank Brian Chuck and of
course Kelly for making this show happen
you've been listening and possibly even
watching Startalk and as always I bid
you to keep looking
[Applause]
[Music]